tenir le président du groupe des
sénateurs RDP un dessinateur Renaissance
ici au Sénat François Patriat bonjour
François Patriat on a entendu des voix
qui se réjouissaient ce matin qu'il y
est enfin un débat un débat autour et
bien de l'introduction d'une part de
capitalisation dans notre système qui
aujourd'hui un système par répartition
est-ce que vous y êtes personnellement
favorable je ne suis pas favorable je
suis
dans cette hémicycle en soutien de la
loi que propose le gouvernement qui vise
à protéger et amplifier la répartition
les affaires en sorte que la solidarité
internationale générationnelle se
poursuivent la retraite par
capitalisation on sait ce que ça donne
dans d'autres pays on a vu ce que
peuvent apporter les fonds aléatoires
par ailleurs je pense que je sais très
bien que la retraite par capitalisation
c'est l'affaire de ceux qui peuvent la
payer par ailleurs je prends aujourd'hui
que notre système est exemplaire il est
envié il est meilleur aujourd'hui il est
celui de la répartition reste bien
entendu que ceux qui veulent ou qui
peuvent faire la capitalisation à côté
peuvent le faire personne ne les empêche
dans la loi mais il n'est pas question
de venir à une forme de capitalisation
obligatoire troisième étage d'une fusée
comme évoquée aujourd'hui par le
président des républicains
fonctionner et qui est aléatoire par
ailleurs c'est l'un des rares sujets qui
vous opposent sur ce texte ou les LR
sont plutôt beaux partenaires voir
estime avoir presque la paternité de ce
projet de loi François Patriat je souris
quand j'entends cela parce que le texte
de loi que proposait les républicains
c'était un amendement sec dans le projet
de loi de finances rectificative elle
doit le payer les fesses qui étaient
celui sec il n'était pas question les
carrières longues des carrières hachées
de la pénibilité ou de l'emploi des
seniors donc ça les républicains n'ont
pas la paternité ils veulent aujourd'hui
le modifier à la mort j'en disant ce
sera un autre loi demain non c'est la
loi du gouvernement qui en est le socle
à 98% on acceptera des amendements on
pense juste qu'ils peuvent être demain
qui sont le fruit du débat
encore que le débat ait lieu sereinement
il a lieu sereinement sur la forme mais
sur le fond on est en face dans
l'islement de blocage on a vu des
amendements à répétition hier à la
virgule près par dizaine par centaines
on voit ce matin que en 1h30 près de 2h
on aura fait deux amendements parce
qu'il y a des explications de votre
redondante le comique de répétition
assez limite je peux les supporter je
suis là j'écoute je suis là en soutien
du gouvernement j'espère qu'on pourra
avancer un peu parce que je crois que
tout a été dit sur cette réforme
aujourd'hui il y aurait un seul orateur
dans chaque camp pour expliquer on
gagnera du temps parce que les
répétitions ne sont pas là pour éclairer
le débat vous vous agacez du rythme
actuel vous demandez justement à ce que
et bien on prenne un autre rythme et que
on limite les orateurs sur les prises de
parole il y a un certain nombre de
possibilités dans les règlements du
Sénat notamment l'article 38 dont on a
déjà beaucoup parlé vous appelez à ce
qu'il soit dégainé pour pouvoir aller
plus vite et aboutir à un vote dimanche
je crois que c'est le responsabilité de
la résidence du Sénat si le président il
l'a dit et je lui en Ségré qu'il
souhaitait que le Sénat bis voter quel
est le rôle du Parlement le rôle du
Parlement c'est bientôt tenu de débattre
le débat doit éclairer une décision
faut-il encore que cette décision soit
prise si on dépare dans le vide pendant
des heures et des heures des jours et
des nuits
c'est l'opposition c'est ce que fait la
gauche aujourd'hui manifestement vous
avez vu les amendements de 50 qui
passeraient de 2050 49 39 et tout hier
déposé comme ça 30 amendements avec 30
explications de vote et surtout moi ici
je pense que le règlement du Sénat n'est
plus adapté qu'on est comme ça vient ça
se passe actuellement j'ai quitté
l'hémicycle parce que j'étais un peu
énervé de voir qu'on en était la 30e
explication de vote sur un sous
amendement
très bien que la droite durcir le texte
par ailleurs en disant qu'elles occupent
des plus faibles elle veut le durcir je
crois qu'il y a une question de justice
de parole donnée moi je suis pour le
maintien de la clause du grand-père on
l'a déjà fait pour la SNCF la loi que
nous allons voter doit concerner les
futurs entrants elle ne peut pas
concerner les océans sauf en
l'occurrence pour le minimum contributif
une toute dernière question sur un point
que l'on dont on attend la discussion
aujourd'hui l'article 2 article qui
porte sur l'index seniors la droite
sénatoriale veut instaurer un CDI senior
avec une exonération de cotisation
famille pour ce type de contrats
êtes-vous favorable moi je voudrais
qu'on m'en connaisse le coup aujourd'hui
d'abord l'index seniors il est c'est une
avancée par rapport à ce qui existait
avant et je pense que sur le travail des
seniors nous avons encore du chemin à
parcourir je pense qu'on peut encore
avancer et sur le CDI j'ai pas le
chiffre en tête mais je crois que ça
coûte plusieurs dizaines de
je pense plutôt que le fait je rappelle
que pour l'emploi des seniors tout le
monde dans tous les pays qui nous
entourent que lorsqu'on recule l'âge
légal de la retraite l'emploi des
seniors augmente avec et que les
ruptures conventionnelles diminuent
aussi parce qu'ils se repoussent donc
voilà déjà simplement le fait
aujourd'hui l'employabilité des seniors
elle va progresser en même temps que
progresse là je la retraite sur le CDI
seniors j'attends les arbitrages parce
que la droite peut pas d'un côté nous
dit je veux une réforme à l'équilibre
nous proposer des amendements à 300
millions à chaque instant disant ben
vous avez qu'à retiré les autres
je suis je pense qu'il y est c'est une
formule que l'on peut étudier
aujourd'hui dans quelle condition avec
quel taux et sous quelle forme
d'exonération ou pas parce que c'est
problème des exonérations
donc peut-être y a-t-il une formule à
trouver elle n'est PAS rejeter à priori
faut-il en voir le coach aujourd'hui
comment on peut remonter merci beaucoup
François Patriat
[Musique]